no idiot I'm telling you Merrick is
definitely Kanan Jairus that's literally
impossible number one he did number two
it's Stark iller it's not something it
is not stuck so idiot I don't care why
you keep saying that it's gonna be jar
jar Beach
everyone be quiet we're gonna watch
Ahsoka episode four today thank you to
all who have been on this journey with
us I want to say thank you to all who
have been wishing Greg a happy birthday
but you want to know the best way to
wish Greg a happy birthday real rejects
we left Zero edition and now we have our
own store reject nationshop.com real
rejects tees are all over there right
now and if you want to celebrate Greg's
birthday get him a little present you
know you're supposed to
yourself a real gesture that's where
these uh soda shirts that I've been
wearing are from Michael just got one
himself as well isn't it I love this
design it's just so it's so vintage it's
so cool just like your best I was also
an Urgent Care a couple days ago so give
me some sympathy points and then yeah
yeah there's a little pity buy you know
what I mean it works for YouTubers to do
that it does a Sim birthday leave a like
on this video also full length Reaction
watch along re-sync it with your own
copy of Ahsoka available for super sex
rejects over at our patreon page thank
you to all been joining we covered
several shows exclusive with their
reaction arts and watch along include an
intro done let's get to it
today we find out Merrick's identity has
Barris
sandula
yeah I think we're gonna go to the world
Between Worlds today
I fear we Face a difficult Choice what
choice is that if we can't make the
journey to find Ezra then no one should
um
oh you'll make that Journey Disney
shareholders demand it he'd be stranded
out there better that
and allowing thrawn's return as heir to
the Empire
can I count on you
it's contemplative
you know you can
it's missing some weight I don't know
what it is about the like I want it to
be there it's just not there yet let's
get underway soon is that a note of fear
in your voice
experience
X Furious experience
give me a flashback please
this music
okay okay oh what are we referring to
they usually have dual meanings the Dual
Fates they usually have dual meanings I
mean he's at least one of the Fallen
Jedi yes but Ahsoka is as well her own
experience doesn't quite identify as one
oh it's like portrait rhymes
[Laughter]
should I mean
what
worried
nope talk to each other guys
[Music]
I know how much as it means to you
as it does to everyone who didn't watch
Star Wars Rebels I can't wait to see him
sometimes we have to do what's right
regardless of our personal feelings just
like what Ezra said gotta make the
hardest choices
hmm
kick some ass yeah
Droid fight
why did I not know I needed this
I have more than just the one speaker
smart
Mandalorian Jedi
ately
that's cool
yeah honestly who needs the force she's
doing great look at that teamwork
nice you to show up to yang
due to contact General sindula as soon
as you can of course we need the ghost
crew Stay Together you've always did
better that way in my opinion
we
better get moving
together
I see what y'all did there
[Music]
like their Uncle oh and Alfred ah I just
no matter how old I am that's so cool
God look it's
[Music]
my God this is gonna be with them
no when you're a general you can disobey
orders too until then
no yeah buckle up private can we please
pick up Zeb on the way
no you gotta leave something for season
two man
oh no way she's got the squad awesome
thanks for joining the party Carson
once a rebel always a rebel
on your signal Phoenix leader
all right all right all right all right
you go
space cap
Zab Zab Zab zap sorry
they would have just throw them in that
way those were all really important
characters the Rangers of the new
Republic your calculations are off we
will be lost to the depths of the Void
have faith
faith
I lost that a long time ago when I fell
from being a Jedi
love seeing
baffamir just come to life
witchcraft
actually though
oh here you go
I think we're gonna get something really
big at the end of this I've got a
feeling you're right
they've given us a nice buildup
oh boy
I am Starkiller and Ezra Bridger and
this is going somewhere
out to dinner to the world Between
Worlds
oh Revenge fight
I bet we're not going to learn anything
about this guy's identity he's just a
random character I would not put that
path that's there's an interesting I'll
put money on that even the way she's
she's looking at them just
there's some kind of connection there
would be cool if they took the helmet
off this episode
live action Inquisitor fights
dough bladed lightsaber fighting that's
cool and we got one in a long time it's
interesting if it is Starkiller they
share similar lightsaber forms from
Anakin
come on come on get your lightsaber out
so that's how you take a helmet off
you're out of the Creed again oh good
Dodge
there we go in the waters again
very up close camera work on this all
right very intimate
again Kevin kleiner's music is amazing
it was made for the big screen yes on
Disney Plus
[Music]
she's growing frustrated I love how
that's how they've embraced the samurai
Style with her
come on
all right all right
oh she's gonna get that perfect strike
in there yeah a perfect strike come on
come on man
whoa this is Nautica
there it is
whoa we can't end it there yep we will
yeah you can't hype fans like that cool
mask and that's it all right
whoa he's he's just
Shadows stuff what was that wait that
looked like dathomir magic it might have
been yeah it could have been the
embodiment of that wait maybe it was
Kaden
[Music]
fascinating
[__] [__] [__] [__]
come on you had that day of training
Sabine
protect the map
until I sent for you
so maybe Merrick was just some like
vessel thing or there's just an alien
that is dashes it's like the Seth uh
McFarlane character in cowboy too and
tales of the Jedi there was a when
Ahsoka killed that Inquisitor there was
a similar kind of deflation it was
concentrated
a fight I've been waiting for Anakin
spoke highly of you you Anakin okay
interesting
he never mentioned you everyone in the
order knew Anakin Skywalker if you would
live to see what he became I'm so
intrigued right now surely that must
leave a mark
huh is that why you walked away
abandoned him
I'm loving the vibe of this I'm not here
to discuss my past but you have [__] to
get over the only reason I'm here
is to secure the future common goal
another star war Throne will
it is an unfortunate evil but speaks to
a greater truth
Must Destroy in order to create
them lightsabers
you in these writing sessions how
inevitable
oh boy
ah
such beautiful hilt
Gothic keep teasing my dick with
information about this guy yes
um
no one wants to strike first
whatever people say about this show I
love the Shogun approach to the
lightsaber duels there's a lot in this
yeah it's very striking
and unique
definitely a stun double there okay
now that's happening
I appreciate that he's playing a more
Western
medieval style she's very much has this
finesse and he's just aggressive
[Music]
ah take that
not bad
[Music]
whoa awesome that's similar acrobatic
skills coming to play
[Music]
oh no
become the Jedi
oh boy oh
I'm gonna have to use the force yeah
it's gonna come out a moment of stress
made you Flinch that's embarrassing
[Music]
foreign
let that paint out Ahsoka
[Music]
ow oh yeah
and for my next
there's going to be a moment where
Sabine uses so much force
was unwind
now it's both our ass time for the
Padawan
[Music]
yes let that anger out oh it's dangerous
given to the dark side of Soca
oh yeah
just shoot him destroy it
or the map gets it
no no dang
she's in the world Between Worlds again
oh she's gonna go with him yes do what
your master says
destroy it
you sense I know you feel that Ezra
Bridger
the only family you have left
what about Hera
your family died on Mandalore
okay because your master didn't trust
you oh well there it is that's real all
that resentment comes in you and I share
a common goal
this journey oh wow yeah
come with me he's so good at
manipulating young woman huh
we could learn a lot from this guy you
will be reunited with your friend
foreign
maybe you already have been
I promise you've been looking for but it
feels so dark
do it
you would do it
there it is
thought of that yeah I feel the weight
of it like the like the ring from Lord
of the Rings cold metal
oh no
[Music]
over my word and unlike her former
master I shall keep mine
he's so much presence yeah we really
love something special with him didn't
we the hyperspace route has been
established
it's honestly the best thing that
happened to Star Wars in years dang
[Music]
let's go what can you tell me
has built a massive hyperspace ring
it's undermine why would she bring him
that's so dangerous it does seem like a
very inopportune time to take your kid
to work today
return at once understood
[Music]
the ghost is getting stuck there in the
portal
oh no
one will be following us
[Music]
you regret every decision
wow sick sick sick
damn that is gorgeous
oh
Hera
oh yeah maybe maybe
ignore them
Engage The hyperdrive
oh boy
we're all going for a ride
I just want to see this new world I'm so
excited what does a different galaxy
look like you know something Star Wars
designers would come up with
wow
foreign
[Music]
Carson's beard
I've got a bad feeling
interesting time for we all do so that
line
he's Force sensitive he's feeling
figuring it out
I wonder if when she grabbed it
pergil
they don't need the map
oh whoa whoa is she actually in the
world I think she's in the world Between
Worlds again oh Anakin's gonna be here I
totally feel it too I can feel this
person I can feel Anakin
[Music]
oh wow
oh yeah oh yeah called it
what have you known this day
that's gorgeous yeah
she's like a backyard
master
I didn't expect to see you
[Music]
one in the timeline will he be
yes
hell yeah
laughs
the Anakin
[Music]
yeah has a tune in next week for you
somebody pulled her in
who maybe him or Ezra Bridger pulled her
in and so did Kane and Jairus and so did
well I mean Ezra already did once all
right let's talk about it guys all right
John
it's definitely ended off in a very
intriguing place and uh and yeah I mean
I'm
I'm fascinated by how these Star Wars
shows move and I have been pretty well
kind of grabbed by this thus far in the
past couple of episodes I have been
sitting here going okay these very
linear straightforward action oriented
I'm ready for something to kick
something to evolve you know the next
chapter of the story to begin and that
seems uh evidently what is about to
happen both spiritually and physically
and uh and I really do appreciate
it's interesting
I'm excited for what's to come I really
appreciate the fact that they are going
for something a bit more brooding a bit
more Airy and a bit more deliberate I
have been sitting here kind of it's It's
it was interesting watching this episode
because Ray Stevenson has
so much presence all the time when he's
on screen and I can always feel the
depths that I think they want me to feel
from everybody when he is on so there
are times where I find myself yeah a
little bit kind of waiting for some real
emotional story to kick back up
especially between say Ahsoka and Sabine
and I don't often or always feel the
unsaid stuff as much with them and I'm
waiting for that but this episode did
certainly kind of grab me again and go
okay maybe we're about to get to the
point where some real challenges are
going to be met and also some real world
building is going to happen so uh so
yeah I am I'm optimistic I enjoyed this
episode and it certainly kind of
I don't want to say God better it's
gotten along because I didn't think it
got bad at any point but yeah I'm at a
point where I've been kind of ready for
a next gear to be shifted into and I
feel like this was gonna happen so uh
so yeah
pretty solid episode I would say
Michael
well you know
this
this has so many pieces uh that have
been missing
I think the I completely agree about
like Ray Stevenson the
that is a character that has like
Dimension and there's something so
fascinating and interesting that you
just you want to know more
and it definitively enhances everybody's
performance when he's on screen
um I think this episode for the first
time I really was like oh this must
really be rough to not be a Rebels fan
like in in that they're they're dropping
a lot they're doing I think the best job
that they can in terms of like trying to
handle the just the sheer volume of
exposition but uh I can only imagine
that this is a challenge and I think the
heart of that challenge
comes from a very simple fact that you
have an amazing actor as Ahsoka and you
have an amazing actor as Sabine and I
think the two of them have zero
chemistry together as talent and it
shows and it sucks because I want them
to and I'm waiting for them to and for a
while I thought well maybe this is just
the the goal of the writing
um but in reality I'd I just think that
relationship has fallen flat that being
said I don't think that the series
because of that is a lost cause there's
so much that it does right
and it's learning from uh and and I'm
excited to see where it goes you know
I'm I'm particularly excited I think
Ahsoka as a character and her challenges
I'm hoping that by getting to see her
Dynamic with Anakin in the world Between
Worlds which like
I just can't believe that I just saw
that in live action like it's insane
um I'm hoping that that will create an
opportunity
for fans that maybe don't know Ahsoka to
fall in love with Ahsoka and to really
understand why her character is so
important not just to the story but to
Star Wars itself and and what she
represents and what she's grown into and
and become
um because I really
like I know there's always a lot of like
on the internet about like well I have
two female leads this was actually the
first Star Wars content ever where two
women with lightsabers had their
lightsabers Clash which is kind of
insane to think that that's just the
first time it's happened the Beck Del
saber fights
I love it but you know I think Ahsoka as
we talk about like authentic
representation and like doing a good job
and having characters that are
meaningful and playing a role when
Ahsoka first joined the Star Wars
universe as Anakin's Padawan she kind of
universally hated and over time through
writing and through building character
you watch this little girl grow up into
like the ultimate badass and you know I
think there's a generation of fans uh
who really identify with her and I'm
excited for people that have not
necessarily gone to the Clone Wars
journey and the rebels journey to
finally have the chance to see the
Ahsoka that we fell in love with
um
so I know that was a lot of thoughts I
apologize I have to apologize I'm sorry
oh well apology accepted thank you what
did you think Greg
I think it's
I'm conflicted I'm conflicted because uh
I I like everything that you guys said
you liked and
um I'm just my I guess my I fluctuate so
much I thought that my connection to
Sabine and Ahsoka in particular finally
was coming in play last episode and then
here was kind of lost again because
there's so much of this something
happened between them uh off screen you
know like I think even if you're a
Rebels fan you know no I've seen this
thing I've seen Rebels and I'm like well
I'll just have it off screen and they
just they do a lot of this John Wick
like dialogue which is cool in a movie
but we're on we're watching a television
series like this whole shrouded in
mystery type of dialogue stuff like okay
a lot of it's just I I I need more meat
here I need I need more substance here
and it's like stoic is not bad I I don't
think stoic is bad but it can feel a
little dull I mean honest in terms of
their Dynamic right because there's a
lot of really interesting things that
are are happening here
um I feel like the Merrick thing is
something that will probably put people
up in arms
um
yeah we'll talk about that yeah we'll
touch on that uh we'll talk about Anakin
and all that and yeah I I mean like I I
guess I am at a point with this shows
were four episodes how many are there
eight there's eight yeah okay six or
eight something like that right
um six word trouble because I feel like
a four day it seemed like the
conversation with Balin and Ahsoka was
the thing that they're trying to set up
for Ahsoka which is going after her past
right and I kind of feel like uh in
terms of writing and and doing a story
about a character the Title Character
Ahsoka hmm the uh the the emotional
depth to her
is not really something that's truly
been set up in this show it's like
they've had like a line here or there
but in terms of focus in terms of
emphasis in terms of being an audience
member connected to the journey that
she's supposed to go on on this show
isolated not factoring in countless
episodes of Clone Wars and her
appearances and Rebels and tales of the
jet like all this [__] it's just going
off of this show alone and I feel like
what they're what they're setting up is
that she has guilt uh towards stuff
that's happened like she's she's saying
I'm not here to talk about the past
she's trying to solve a problem here all
this [__] with Anakin of her being of
her uh leaving him behind because like
the last sequence of events with Anakin
did not go down that well like she did
not she left she was disillusioned by
the Jedi Order and then as Ahsoka and
Rebels she fights Darth Vader you know
and it comes to the realization of that
and then pull between the world Between
Worlds there's this whole thing here
where I understand why she could
probably have a lot of pain in her and
have this uh issues with trust and
whatnot
but that's a lot of me going in there
with a lot of Canon and a lot of other
[__] that I'm applying myself and I and
and so I'm like when I say I'm a a
Crossroads here it's because I'm a Star
Wars fan and I know all this information
and it's more so how is this being
communicated in terms of this medium and
this in the in the specific story
they're trying to tell because right now
I do feel it's a bit of a void when it
comes to what they're pitching as the
heart of the story which is Ahsoka and
Sabine and that right there I just don't
feel much for and and then for ahsoka's
own personal story I'm like I don't
really feel much for that I'm excited at
the at the prospect of live action
because you know Anakin Skywalker
adapting to clone wars was meant to look
like hating Christians and so it's cool
like oh [__] we're gonna see Ahsoka and
Anakin interacting with each other yeah
that's [__] awesome like I'm no doubt
that's really cool to me I don't care
what crazy will it be able to to achieve
what you're talking about is the
yeah it's because it's like they didn't
really set us up or build I don't feel
like they really built to that yeah
whatever it is I think there's a like
yes I feel like I was just like 10. no
no no no no no no no no no no no
you go first but big yep sorry I'm just
holding in a lot of things right now I
think there is a
there is a critical mistake that was
made
the first episode of this show in my
opinion should have taken place during
the original
apprenticeship with Sabine and Ahsoka I
think that we should have seen them
jiving having a good time and then we
should have seen that like like Obi-Wan
and Anakin that there is a little bit of
of friction and stuff and then the siege
of Mandalore which I I'm assuming that
where the dot connects here and like
where they're hoping that we assume is
that everything that we know about the
destruction of Mandalore is when her
family was killed it's a great way to
tie it all in together and then kind of
pick it up from there where we've we've
spent a little bit of time with these
characters in this dynamic because
even though we've seen all of the
content
we're still left in the dark in terms of
like this dynamic in this relationship
like they didn't really have anything in
Rebels they were they barely interacted
yeah and so if you're like I've seen
Rebel I'm like Bubble Soccer and and
Sabine didn't really like todgers and
that's like and and I think that's hard
because you have
uh
you have a character that has so much
Nuance in her relationships in the form
of Ahsoka and yet she hasn't interacted
with any of the other characters that
she would have that Dynamic with yeah
um and I I think that that's just kind
of
it gets to the the heart of
not just this
series issue but I think kind of across
the board is that
it's it almost kind of feels like too
little too late like the the need for
that comprehensive story that is easy
and linear to follow for people and in
live action yeah like there was a window
for that and that window is closed and
now we have this very like confused
hodgepodge like timeline wise I'm just
like constantly confused and I'm I'm
theoretically I know my stuff when it
comes to Star Wars so
you know I I don't know I don't know how
to rescue that dynamic in that
relationship I feel like this is a lot
of cool like what it's serving in terms
of man that
I think it's serving a lot of cool lore
yeah I think it's a lot of lore building
it's a lot of world expansion it's a lot
of World building
and history building and whatnot
um but at the end of the day
in terms of its story I'm like wow
everything aesthetically and tonally I'm
like this is everything that should be
just this should be
Peak Star Wars for me you know
um
but I've I'm constantly like at and it's
so it's just so strange like I'm not
gonna write the show off because there's
so much about it I've Loved yeah yeah
and but then but then by the time we get
to hear I'm like this is this is like
the big climax of a lot of these
characters converging and I think that's
why the problem comes in you got Merrick
um fighting Ahsoka and then it's like
what the [__] there you got Shin
fighting Sabine and and Sabine making
the choice and I think what happened
with me would it when the sh weirdly
when it started to lose me in this
episode was when they were talking about
I know how much Ezra means to you and
stuff and I'm like
[Music]
it's kind of weird that you have to
really set like
a way to do it and to get the people who
have seen everything comprehensively as
well as the people like me who have only
seen like scattered episodes of these
shows here or there I feel like you
could have laced a lot of through the
characters we care about who are on
screen you can care about people who are
not on screen yeah you don't even need
to do a flashback to do that and and
this episode brought me to a place that
I've heard people complain about for the
Mandalorian up until this point and I
finally started to feel with that show
about season three where it's like I can
feel the writing kind of spinning wheels
and not really
I admire when people set something up
and instead of being like but we're
gonna push that out we're just gonna
keep hint I feel like this is learned
bad lessons from the JJ Abrams Mystery
Box theory of like I get it there's a
bunch of mumbo jumbo but nothing is all
that tangible to make me really care
about wanting to see the answer to those
Mysteries and I think you could solve
that problem without having to you know
Mainline like a whole bunch of yes
thousands of hours of other things and I
can feel them pulling or saving punches
when I'm like Sabine and Ahsoka should
already have had like some kind of big
old back and forth talk or something
like yeah there are so many ways to
approach it and I feel like they're
going for Vibe they're going for cool
imagery they're going for some lore but
they're really kind of dawdling in terms
of actual storytelling that you might
care about and this whole thing up until
this point as of this episode has felt
like some extended prologue to me where
like I should have seen some kind of
team form or some kind of dynamic should
have been established but again the most
solid Dynamic on screen is literally uh
uh bailing and shin you know not kind of
elsbeth and that's all stuff that too
again from more of the outside I'm
ancient witch order awesome I am already
interested you know uh Jedi who are you
know sort of in the middle and one has
clearly Fallen more since one has
clearly Fallen more toward the light
zone fascinating but then they even
Ahsoka meeting balen and having that
Face-Off was kind of a bummer at the end
of it because I was like oh this is
gonna be a scene and it was like a half
a fight you know which was cool but yeah
I just don't think that they're really
biting into all the stuff that they've
laid out onto the table you know it's
kind of interesting that the characters
that we assumed were gonna be like the
real meat and potatoes have turned out
to be
the like broccoli of the show yeah man
you know and for Hera like I don't know
a ton about Hera but I feel like I would
be bummed if I did because she's just
been like in the background driving
around this whole time not as
interesting as I had hoped yeah she's
just like bickering with people but
politics everyone has had like an
isolated moment or two where like that's
a great scene but in terms of their
their long their longest anymore like
honestly it's these Fallen Jedi
characters they're the best ones yeah
they're the shin and Balin they're the
most dynamic and they're the most
compelling yeah and they both have like
all that life and presence even when
they're not yeah I love them
um
what's the Merrick Theory see the
numeric Theory we got it you know it's
like we've made our Point yeah I think I
feel like we were obviously we'll wrap
it up I gave on our emotional side here
yeah well I think the the Merrick
listen there was always the very high
likelihood that it was nobody
um hilarious I do think no that was the
funny you know I it definitely did look
like death the mere magic that was
coming out like that green but also
literally it could have just been like a
gaseous Inquisitor who knows
but you know that's Star Wars for you
like I mean I think about how much time
like the internet spent sleuthing being
like who is snoke turns out he's just
snoke you know he's just a cologne thing
like
I've made nothing it's a little bit more
if they don't explain what that is I
think that is [__] not because it's
not Starkiller not because it's not
Paris not because it's not Ezra why I
think it's [__] is because it is an
Inc they literally the whole embodiment
is an Inquisitor yeah it's an Inquisitor
with this dual lightsaber yeah and and
then even like when on screen when he
first shows up or it shows up it's like
oh what it that that poses it in a way
of like who is this yes you know and
like whatever Oh I thought the
inquisitors were dead and everyone on
the team that they're focusing on is
important and if they don't explain yeah
what that is you know then it's [__]
Shin definitely cared a lot like that
much with was evident which gives me a
little bit of hope that we'll go back
and explore it like yeah I think you're
gonna be like on the ship well there's
made a moment out of it yeah exactly you
know I think the there there's always
kind of the the one rumor that I kind of
brushed off but who knows of it could
have been
um no during the yes
anti-semitic Inquisitor
[Music]
but uh during the the temple sequence
um when all the inquisitors in in Rebels
you know when they're like flying around
with their little helicopter lightsabers
yes which we're just gonna pretend that
never happened because it was ridiculous
um but it was theorized that it was one
of them
who then was like resurrected by The
dathmir Witches which makes sense like
that but why would she oh she needs Dark
Side Centric for too much everyone
predicted cooler things
actually can we check the credits really
quick to see if they finally said who it
was playing him yeah they said it uh is
it Sam Peter uh no no I wasn't saying
what were it was uh name I've never
heard of before
um well that that grinds my gears Peter
Griffin
um I don't know it's all right I I'm
disappointed and I don't care anymore
um either way listen we get to see
Anakin so at a minimum we get that and
if that's all we get then that's fine
um I do
I got it on the app
omology
rewinding let's wait I'll tell you right
now
um well we build suspense here
it's also interesting that they didn't
credit him prior like like
Paul Darnell okay
all darn now
sorry Paul because it's done it's so
good who is Paul one hour ago
uh
[Music]
there's a stunt man who plays and maybe
even voices
I don't think he voiced him unless he
comes back in his own form to be an
actor too he's been a red guard before
sure all right yeah congratulations
everyone well um yeah you know and he
was a cloud of black smoke this is this
is the life of a Star Wars fan yeah and
I'm not hurt
because I signed up for it I don't I
mean it's it's annoying if we don't
learn but I'm not going to be annoyed
until I'm not learning until until
episode eight unless if episode 8 comes
around and we don't know Jack about it
then I'm gonna be like that's annoying
yeah but right now I'm not gonna be
annoyed Between Worlds I'm I'm more like
or four episodes in I gotta
I gotta care a little bit more for this
one what if the ball is in the world
between ones this time I'm not I'm done
I'm done every character we want to see
is in the world
that was a joke for the record I want
um I care and I'm hoping that next
episode
is truly an emotionally core focused
episode about Ahsoka because you know
like right now I don't know like I I I
think I thought Sabine wrench should
have been this the lead of Star Wars
Rebels personally she was the best
character to me and she should have been
the lead to me yeah but then her
translation for this show I'm like it's
a good actress but the the writing is
it's not there it's it's not there it's
not there it's it it has not been it has
not been there and I'm like your
Intrigue button is not pushing it for me
and I think the issue is Sabine as a
character grew so much during Rebels
and I feel like the same thing that we
got is like right back to square one I
hated the line about uh your your family
is your only family like the hair is
right there yeah you literally just
shouted for her career and like in like
she and you would think after like the
relationship that with all this Rebels
connection that they rely on that with
uh the connection that she had with
Kanan Sabine that she'd want to know
Jason a little bit you know
like it's just like [__] that it that
[__] like that is just yeah I don't know
they
yeah I think they're at a cross I think
the show is at a Crossroads because of
the exact problem of well I just want to
tell my sequel to Rebels but a lot of
people haven't seen Rebels so I gotta
tell something that could still be
accessible so I gotta kind of write
things down the middle so I don't left
people feeling left out but then now I'm
missing Nuance because
now people who haven't seen Rebels have
no idea what the hell's going on here
you could do this in a way that compels
those people to go watch it and I think
we could we would care about as her
looking for Ezra if we cared more about
it doesn't even matter if we know Ezra
or not yeah what matters is how much it
would mean like when they're having that
line of like we know like you can't just
tell me how much
Ezra means I'm like you gotta have a
scene where I [__] feel that [__]
yeah and I feel nothing when you say
that because right now it just feels
like action guy has family needs to go
yeah and honestly the little hologram
that they showed of Ezra made me kind of
not want to see Ezra
it's like this guy's a little punk uh
yeah
um whatever
um we still haven't seen thrawn yeah I'm
excited for thrawn and now I honestly I
think what I'm concerned about
is that it's just you're gonna save them
for like two no but like what if if the
writing doesn't
I think we're gonna get a lot of Rich
philosophical I hope so cool bars from
thrawn
I'll take it um and that's what we're
gonna get guys what did you think about
this episode I like the action I like
the visuals I like the tone but uh yeah
we're looking at three very conflicted
fans right now
um haven't written it off haven't made a
decision on the show yet
it has time still rooting for us let's
see what happens leave your thoughts
down below and we'll talk to you guys
soon thanks for being here